bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires seller de parlement hebdo
avec thomas souliers bonjour thomas jean
miquel et pendant 45 minutes nous allons
revoir l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine mauvaise
semaine pour le gouvernement
sur le front économique la croissance
sera nulle
les prévisions sont revues à la baisse
les ministres ont tapé à coeur encore
des économies pourtant françois hollande
perd 6 il ne veut pas entendre parler du
mot rigueur
et puis la loi sur le non-cumul des
mandats une promesse du candidat
hollande qui ne devrait pas être
appliquée avant la fin du quinquennat
alors au ps on grince des dents le
premier secrétaire venant référendum la
droite elle crée son club
cumulard et fier de l'être enfin le
salon de l'agriculture ouvre ses portes
ce week-end sur fond d'affaires de la
viande de fans et des craintes du
consommateur le salon fête ses 50 ans
petite et grande histoire à la fois
notre mission est pour commenter cette
semaine politique barbara pompili
bonjour vous êtes co président du groupe
écologiste ici même à l'assemblée vous
partager ce titre avec françois de rugy
alors dans les couloirs les plus amicaux
vous appelle un gars une fille d'autres
ken et barbie ce qu'est le don de vous
agacer dit ans et pourtant et pourtant
derrière le personnage de soeur sourire
comme vous surnomme libération veut bien
vous avez réussi en quelques mois à vous
imposer dans ce monde viril mais
vraiment très viril du temps du palais
bourbon la preuve vous arriver
aujourd'hui à faire la quasi unanimité
dans vos rangs on s'en douter mais aussi
dans l'opposition vous allez le voir
cécile freixinos écrit biz ont posé leur
caméra salle des quatre colonnes la
question est simple que pensez-vous de
barbara pompidou et bien la réponse est
plutôt flatteuse regarder quand on se
lance dans le grand bain
d'une élection législative et qu'on est
élu et qu'ensuite on devient
co-président d'un groupe
ça fait beaucoup en une seule année en
quelque sorte et elle y est arrivée très
bien la démontrer tous ces derniers mois
de façon magistrale vous a beau être
président ce que vous voulez s'il va
subir assumer mal votre présidence vous
déconnez pas pour autant et là je trouve
qu'un parlementaire parlementaire pour
la première fois depuis six mois et qui
a déjà ce niveau de notoriété est
important dans le paysage politique
français
c'est bien ça prouve un parlementaire de
grande qualité la franchise est les
caches et les directs et puis c'est une
bosseuse
or on l'a bien vu sur plusieurs des
textes sur lesquels elle et elle est
intervenue
moi j'ai une question qui me taraude
depuis quelques semaines et la
difficulté et qui elle a eu avec sa
résolution cheikh barbara comment
comment allez vous faire pour assurer
une une coprésidence officielles pour
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
un flatteur vous le disais vous allez
pouvoir répondre un film que cela je le
rappelle péter spectateurs vous avez
fait voter une proposition de loi
pourquoi un groupe parlementaire puisse
être dirigée résolution pardon puisse
être dirigée par un homme et par une
femme c'est la part était alors dans les
faits vous l'avez appliquez-vous groupes
écologistes cette résolution mais aucun
autre groupe politique de compte le
faire c'est plutôt un échec non barbara
pompidou non je n'ai vraiment pas au
contraire je suis très contente qu'on
ait réussi à valider cette avancée qui
est une avancée mais qui correspond
aussi à notre culture politique à nous
les écologistes on veut pas de l'imposer
à tout le monde ce qu'on veut c'est
montrer que c'est possible et le
démontrer par le fonctionnement de notre
groupe parce que l'on pense que si on
veut attirer des jeunes des femmes des
gens qui ont des responsabilités
familiales aussi il faut qu'on puisse
partager des tâches dans ce monde
politique où les réunions le soir le
week-end ou en gros si on n'a pas 100%
de son temps on ne peut pas le faire
correctement
ou en tout cas en tout cas faire autre
chose que de la figuration moi ce que je
voudrais c'est que les femmes et les
jeunes arrêtent de faire de la
figuration en politique et des vraies
responsabilités on le montre après que
les autres groupes politiques et une
culture différente
voilà on entend bien ce n'est pas grave
les choses avancent
il faut accepter que ça n'avance pas
aussi vite que nous on voudrait mais
c'est un premier pas dans ton est très
fier est ce que vous êtes étonnés par ce
que disent les parlementaires c'est un
portrait plutôt flatteur
oui bah écoutez ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir seulement ou est-ce que c'est
trop rare pour être honnête non écoutez
vous avez interrogé des gens avec qui
les relations jugées sont plutôt saine
et constructive
je pense que ce que j'apporte peut-être
c'est justement une volonté d'abord de
renouveler un petit peu la vie politique
et puis de casser le côté langue de bois
c'est vrai c'est un duo qui disait ça
c'est vrai que j'ai un peu ce côté là et
je voudrais ne pas trop le perdre
d'ailleurs parce que alors même si quand
on est débutant on a tendance trop
souvent avoir à parler trop vite et à se
rendre compte que parfois effectivement
avec le système médiatique faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit et réfléchir un
peu avant de parler
donc je pense qu'il faut essayer de
faire l'idée c'est à dire de ne jamais
perdre
je ne veux pas perdre ma spontanéité je
ne veux pas perdre ma franchise
politique
en même temps je suis consciente que
j'ai des responsabilités que je suis
présidente de groupe que je représente
mon groupe
donc il faut aussi que je fasse
attention à ce que je dis donc commenter
toute l'actualité avec nous et on
commence le lundi avec une bataille de
femmes c'est la bataille de paris est
allée lancé cette bataille elles sont
nombreux sur la ligne de départ anne
hidalgo ça on le savait et nkm qui a
annoncé sa candidature et peut-être
cécile duflot qui laisse entretenir le
mystère les forces en présence avec
ahmed tazir candidat tout pas candidate
interrogé sur les municipales à paris
cécile duflot le répète elle n'a pas
encore pris sa décision mais attention à
la joute rien n'était exclu vous
n'excluez pas dites vous de vous
présenter à la mairie de paris aux
municipales de 2014 quand prendrez-vous
votre décision vous savez ça fait je
crois maintenant un an que je réponds la
même chose à cette question donc comme
j'ai répondu la même chose dimanche je
vais vous dire la même chose lundi
voilà la question se pose pas pour moi
maintenant dans sa famille politique on
n'est pas forcément enthousiastes
dominique voynet n'y va pas
quatre chemins je pense qu'ils vont pas
courir trop de lièvres à la fois que
cécile duflot et et jeunes qu'elle a un
énorme avenir devant elle parce qu'elle
est très bonne et très brillante et qu'
elle doit réussir ce qu'elle fait au
gouvernement c'est vital pour nous si sa
candidature se confirme cécile duflot
affronterez en 2014
nathalie kosciusko morizet rachida dati
pour l'ump et gally d'algos pour le
parti socialiste les municipales à paris
vers une bataille de fable moi je trouve
le défi trois femmes pour paris je
trouve ça passionnant et je peux être
elle pourrait démontrer qu'on peut avoir
des projets différents mais faire de la
politique autrement entre femmes donc
d'être concurrentes
sans être des adversaires mais déjà des
attaques premier missile tiré par anne
hidalgo en direction de nkm madame
kosciusko morizet n'est pas aujourd'hui
une élue parisienne elle quitte
l'abandonnent d'une certaine façon les
habitants de longjumeau à qui elle
juraient fidélité il ya encore quelques
mois
je voudrais paris ouvre à nouveau la
voix il ya des révolutions à faire dans
le numérique dans l'écologie et je
voudrais faire avec les parisiens à lui
d y ont va désigner son candidat pour
paris à la fin du mois parmi les noms
cités des anciennes ministres comme
chantal jouanno rama yade de femmes
encore alors comme le dit daniel cohn
bendit est ce que ce combat de trois
femmes pour la mairie de paris
ce serait un combat passionnant même si
on se doute que dans les propos de
daniel cohn-bendit s'est pas fait pour
arranger cécile duflot oui non on peut
que se réjouir que de voir que sur la
capitale de la france il y ait beaucoup
de femmes qu'ils soient jugés comme
crédible pour exercer donc le donc la
fonction de maire moi je trouve que
c'est très bien que ça ça dit quelque
chose aussi sur les beaux messieurs
voilà sur l'évolution de notre paysage
politique et franchement on ne peut que
s'en réjouir et surtout qu'en plus ce
sont plutôt des femmes jeunes et donc
qu'ils peuvent effectivement montré que
la politique n'est pas réservé qu'aux
ados vous écoute c'était du feu les
candidates un message en sait rien du
tout ah non non je ne sais pas ce que
vous le souhaitez au final ce que l eau
gouvernement est ce qu'elle doit quitter
le gouvernement et venir à paris est ce
que au fond vous vous le souhaitez non
mais ce que je souhaite d'abord et c'est
vrai alors après on va me dire que c'est
de la langue de bois mais c'est vrai
c'est bien de prévenir avant ce que je
souhaite vraiment c'est que on montre
qu'on est utile au gouvernement et donc
cécile est un poste extrêmement
important au gouvernement elle à ddd des
sujets très importants pour nous
notamment maîtrise de l'énergie dans le
logement et l'accès au logement pour
tous
il faut qu'elle fasse qu'elle montre
notre utilité dans son dans son job de
ministre
après voilà c'est dans son jus dit
quelque part reste ministre ne vient pas
sur eux est géré à la fin de l'année ce
qu'elle aura fait parce qu'elle a elle a
une année importante devrait on verra à
la fin de l'année ce qu'elle aura fait
moi la décision m'appartient pas ça lui
appartient à l aci europe ecologie les
verts n'y va pas dans cette primaire ou
alors dans cette campagne pour parer à
ce que vous allez arriver à peser face à
li na li d'algues haut à gauche
il n'y a pas de candidat du mal à peser
on le voit c'est vrai et c'est vrai que
la question de notre participation mais
pas seulement à paris 1 pour tout les
municipales dans des listes autonomes ou
dans des listes communes c'est une
question compliquée on est en train d'en
débattre un peu partout mais de toute
façon il faut qu'on soit dans le débat
et il faut qu'on pèse dans le débat
quels que soient les choix qu'on va
faire et ça va faire partie justement
des choix qu'on va faire est ce qu'on
sera plus présent dans des bases si on
est en autonomie ou si on est en
alliance
et puis les municipales vous savez c'est
quand même vraiment là ne l'élection
locale par excellence est-ce qu'on
remplace son maire ou est-ce qu'on
remplace pas c'est ça la vraie question
est donc les situations sont très
différentes d'un endroit à l'autre je
sais pas si on peut faire une vraie
stratégie nationale là dessus la
question sur paris il faut être écolo
pour gagner paris ou pas ce qu'on voit
que toutes les candidates en tout cas où
cette fibre là bas en tout cas je vois
que l'écologie est au coeur du débat à
paris et je m'en réjouis parce que paris
c'est aussi une vitrine pour la france
donc tout ce qui sera fait à paris sera
un exemple pour le reste de la france à
l'an passé homardiers quand la rigueur
devient un mot tabou
et bien non il n'y aura pas de nouveau
plan de rigueur jean marc ayrault a ball
martelé et pourtant les mauvais chiffres
de la croissance font penser le
contraire certes aucune hausse d'impôts
n'est clairement affichée mais voilà le
gouvernement envisage de nouvelles
économies et de nouvelles réformes
drastiques à cela ajoutez la cacophonie
du gouvernement sur les prévisions de
croissance et vous obtenez le feuilleton
de la semaine il est saigné johan raud
là le plus gros tabou du moment prévoir
la croissance française après une année
2012 de quasi récession le gouvernement
tablait sur 0 8% pour son budget cette
année
prédiction un peu optimiste confirme du
bout des lèvres
laurent fabius maintenant comme au
niveau de l'europe les choses n'ont pas
l'air d'aller une manière bien fameuse
on va être obligé de la de la revoir en
baisse mais le point sur lequel vous
avez une idée je ne sais pas on va voir
ce doit être fait dans les temps les
jours qu'ils avaient 2 0 3 où il c'est
autour de ce chiffre
quand un ministre des affaires
étrangères des voiles de bien mauvaises
nouvelles l affaire ressemble à s'y
méprendre à un incident diplomatique
à l'issue de l'interview communiqué
immédiat de bercy comme le ministre de
l'économie pierre moscovici l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises la prévision de
croissance pour 2013 n'est pas arrêté
car il y à une procédure pour
l'opposition les changes aura du mal à
rester inaperçus c'est invraisemblable
c'est dire qu'on a le le ministre des
affaires étrangères qui annonce une
modification une révision du taux de
croissance
il est immédiatement contredit par bercy
ce qui est certain c'est que la
politique économique qui est conduite
depuis huit mois est catastrophique à la
sortie du conseil interministériel sur
les villes
à charge pour le premier ministre de
jouer les juges de paix comme étant des
meilleurs packs de cacophonie c'est vous
qui la commentent et ce qui est inventé
la cacophonie en a pas il y a la
commission européenne qui dira vendredi
quelles sont les prévisions de
croissance pour la france et pour chacun
des pays d'europe
le chef de l'état a pour sa part
confirmé depuis athènes que la
croissance française devrait bel et bien
être revu à la baisse les hypothèses
pourraient être affinée dès la fin du
mois de mars alors avant d'en venir au
fond des choses dans mot d'abord sur la
forme en le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui parle d'économie démentie
ensuite par bercy ça fait mauvais genre
est ce que c'est le retour des couacs
lors d'un conflit
non mais voilà typiquement moi ce que ce
que j'aime pas en politique c'est
qu'effectivement il ya des ya des
expressions dont on voit que là on a dû
répondre très vite à une question est ce
que c'est ça qui va engager toute la
politique économique de notre de notre
pays n'ont donc je vois que c'est ils
ont rectifié quasiment tout de suite je
viens vraiment pour moi c'est pas ça qui
est intéressant moi ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir qu
effectivement comme on s'y attendait et
comme nous on dit déjà depuis un an les
hypothèses de croissance était un petit
peu optimiste et notamment celle sur le
déficit on voyait bien qu'on pourrait
pas atteindre ces 3 % on savait pourquoi
justement est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement n'a pas dit tout de suite
clairement les choses
oui c'est très très compliqué oui nous
serons à une preview croissance nulle
parce qu'on le savait où personne n'ose
croire que non que personne ne le savait
je pense que le gouvernement lui on
disait et on le répète et on le confirme
je pense que le gouvernement est aussi
dans une position où il a des
interlocuteurs internationaux ou parfois
eh bien il faut dire ce qu'on quelque
part l'objectif plutôt que vraiment ce
qui sera atteint parce que les
partenaires ont besoin de l'entendre la
bottière l'europe notamment avec cette
fameuse règle des déficits des 3%
oui tout à fait que nous nous nous
n'avions pas soutenu ça parce que nous
pensons que c'est un carcan qui est trop
fort et que quelque part bien sûr qu'il
faut avoir des objectifs de rigueur
budgétaire mais j'ai pas peur de ce
terme là je pense que c'est pareil alors
ne vous fait pas peur mais bien sûr
comment alors j'avais déjà dit une fois
sous terme de un petit peu de boutade
rigueur au sens de rigoureuses voilà
avoir une gestion rigoureuse de nos
finances effectivement on est dans une
période très difficile où il faut faire
attention et donc nous nous sommes pour
une gestion rigoureuse et on n'est pas
là pour laisser filer les déficits on
arrive on aurait formé sur le fond les
projets quand on parle les occasions
familiales et pensions de retraite des
réformes sont clairement sur la table
aujourd'hui est ce que vous les soutenez
notamment allocations familiales ce
qu'il faut toucher des allocations
familiales aujourd'hui c'est super de
rigueur ça fait ça fait débat chez nous
moi je pense qu'il faut pas avoir de
tabou sur la question
on est dans une période où effectivement
on a besoin de chercher des sous alors
je moi je pense que ce qui me gêne un
peu c'est cette impression d'aller
chercher un petit peu par ci par là et
qu on vous dirige
voilà je pense qu'il faudrait remettre à
plat un peu tout ça et faire une
politique une réforme fiscale ambitieuse
et qui serait une réforme fiscale un peu
globale où on se poserait des questions
donc un pas seulement sur des petits
bouts comme sur de mesurer le pouls du
temps alors les allocations familiales à
peu je crois que c'est près de 13
milliards d'euros donc on n'est pas sur
des petites sommes
les allocations familiales moi je pense
que si on voulait les revoir il faudrait
réfléchir à pourquoi un enfant vaut plus
qu'un autre pourquoi le premier enfant
ne vaut rien puisque les allocations
familiales ne sont pas donnés au premier
enfant alors que c'est celui qui coûte
le plus cher parce qu'il faut s'équiper
et puis est-ce que effectivement les
familles qui n'en ont pas besoin
c'est à dire les familles très riche à
moi je ne pense pas aux classes moyennes
je pense que les classes moyennes ont
été beaucoup touchées ces dernières
années et qui ne faut pas les pénaliser
mais est-ce que les gros revenus ont
vraiment besoin de ces 300 euros
d'allocations familiales franchement la
question se pose et je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir poser ces questions-là sont
tombés dans les anathèmes que j'ai pu
entendre par ci par là le mot rigueur
vous il ne vous fait pas peur chez
certains ministres non plus mais vous
allez l'entendre des ministres disent
tout haut qu'il faut proposer autre
chose des perspectives plutôt que
rigueur et austérité ils ont été invités
à déjeuner chez le premier ministre et
on va écouter notamment cécile duflot à
la sortie les engagements qui ont été
pris pour 2013 ils ont déjà été pris la
question est déjà réglé pour l'année
2013 et pour le complément les lèvres
mais c'est le calendrier habituel en
arrière nouveau sur le calendrier et le
premier ministre nous a confirmé que les
efforts que nous avions faits sont des
efforts qui sont suffisants pour
affronter la situation pour être
inventifs pour la suite
donc voilà ça va bien tout va bien dit
cécile duflot et pourtant je vais vous
proposer une une du journal du dimanche
était donc dimanche dernier et vous
allez voir cécile duflot baldy pas
vraiment ce qu'elles viennent dire
devant la caméra
l'austérité ne doit pas à clamer
accabler les territoires si c'est pas
une mise en garde
qu'est ce que c'est en fait cécile
duflot ne fait que redire ce que ce que
nous disons c'est à dire que la la
politique rigoureuse notamment en
question de gestion de financière c'est
quelque chose qui doit évidemment nous
guider mais qui ne doit pas être la
seule politique parce que on le voit et
on l'a vu dans les mesures qui ont été
prises au niveau européen que ce soit en
grèce que ce soit dans les pays du sud
l'austérité sun fin de l'austérité la
vraie austérité entraîne austérité et
donc c'est un espèce de c'est un espèce
de cycle sans fin qui fait que une
spirale vers l'échec l'uqar en
revirements deux issus du faux comme ça
si tu joues pour le coup elle dit elle
dit quoi elle dit qu'on a pris des
engagements pour 2013 et ça c'est vrai
mais par contre ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant c'est aussi avoir des idées
est ce qu'elle ne dit pour relancer la
machine et relancer la machine c'est
quoi sert penser à notre industrie
comment on peut maintenant avoir une
industrie plus performante et ça je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de travail là
dessus aussi évidemment relancer notre
économie via la transition énergétique
on voit là que nous avons des gisements
d'emplois et des gisements justement de
compétitivité économique qu'il faut
explorer parce que si on explore pas on
va effectivement tomber dans une spirale
d'austérité qui sera catastrophique on
l'a vu ailleurs
on passe à un autre sujet mardi toujours
mort montebourg a trouvé son ennemi juré
c'est le vôtre aussi barbara pompidou il
s'appelle maurice taylor junior il est
président de titan titan l'entreprise
américaine qui s'est retiré du projet de
reprise de goodyear à amiens c'est dans
votre circonscription est au coeur de la
polémique une lettre envoyée par le pdg
au ministre les salariés français
des revenus élevés mais ne travaille que
trois heures par jour ce qui a suscité
la colère on s'en doute des ouvriers sur
place alors avant de répondre noir sur
blanc avec une lettre à arnaud
montebourg dans un premier temps à
minimiser la faire on va l'écouter c'est
une lettre que j'ai sur laquelle je ne
fais aucun commentaire pour ne pas nuire
aux intérêts de la france
pas davantage malgré un dossier vous
regrettez qu'arnaud montebourg n'est pas
contre attaquer tout de suite et
fermement non mais moi je ne pensais pas
que cette lettre à lettre rendue
publique j'en avais entendu parler déjà
il ya quelques temps puisque arnaud
montebourg nous avait tenus au courant
il nous avait dit qu'il avait
effectivement reçu une lettre au vitriol
de titan non non il ya quelques jours
c'était mes de mardi dans les échos à
neutre oui mais on l'avait sur l'île
avait reçus avant simplement voilà
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça avait un
intérêt particulier de la sortir je n'en
sais rien ce que ça ce que ça montre
simplement et ça moi je suis plutôt
satisfaite c'est que on arrête de
caricaturer dans un sens ou dans un
autre
là on a justement quelqu'un qui a révélé
vraiment des propos mais pour le coup
caricaturaux mais qui permet de qui
permet d'arrêter avec les polémiques ont
en ce moment c'est le gentil repreneur
contre les méchants cgt on voit bien que
la situation est plus complexe que ça
que les syndicats ont eu à négocier avec
jr ewing un mois pour moi se tissent ce
type là voilà un petit peu mais quelque
part qui considère qu'un bon ouvrier est
un ouvrier exploités qui est un ouvrier
payer un euro ou un dollar de l'heure
qu'ils travaillent 24 heures sur 24 est
ce que c'est ça le modèle qu'on veut est
ce que c'est ça pour nous un un vrai
développement économique et pour
l'épreuve de compétitivité il soulève
peut-être aussi là un vrai problème de
compétitivité pour la france
non non moi je pense que je pense que ce
qui soulève c'est que c'est qu'il a une
vision de la france et une vision de
l'économie qui n'est pas la vision mais
moi je pense qu'on pourrait être encore
plus compétitifs avec des esclaves
si on arrêtait de payer les gens juste
on les loge on les nourrit et puis on
les paye plus non mais est ce que c'est
ça vraiment le modèle qu'on veut imposer
dans dans le monde entier
non nous on veut justement plutôt
relever les niveaux sociaux dans les
autres pays on veut effectivement que on
arrête d'exploiter les gens ce modèle là
moi c'est un modèle dont je ne veux pas
et je pense qu'on peut par des
politiques publiques
justement faire évoluer les choses
justement arrêté d'importer des pneus
qui sont fabriqués dans des conditions
sociales terribles surveiller
arnaud montebourg l'adula pas
complètement tort surveillez aussi les
conditions donc en social
environnemental
vous voyez qu'on peut aussi réfléchir à
une régulation du commerce mondial qui
tiendrait compte de ces éléments là qui
sont essentiels on suivra bien
évidemment le dossier de goodyear dans
les prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines maradi encore dehors de votre
traditionnelle réunion de groupe à
l'assemblée vous avez accueilli vincent
peillon le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui en plein débat sur les
rythmes scolaires est venu défendre sa
réforme bec et ongles réformes
contestées par les syndicats mais aussi
par l'opposition mais vincent peillon se
veut rassurant écoutez le il est au
micro de clémentine malgorn et de leurs
bouilhaguet les rythmes scolaires c'est
pas de gauche ou de droite c'était
absolument consensuelle
après chacun selon son organisation fait
comme il peut
j'encourage à passer le plus vite
possible chez qu'ils ne peuvent pas
c'est dans cet état d'esprit qu'on a
rédigé le décret il autorise 2014 c'est
bien pour ça que certains sont saisis
l'important c'est que les choses soient
faites dans l'intérêt des élèves et vous
a convaincu le ministre franchement il a
été convaincant pendant la réunion de
groupe
moi j'ai eu des retours après d'autres
députés qui ont été convaincus par son
enthousiasme par son envie vraiment de
changer l'école est de faire en sorte
que elle apporte plus aux élèves puisque
c'est ce qui nous importe à tous ceux
qui vous a convaincu alors sur la caisse
et il a été même sur ce sujet là il a
été convaincant pourquoi parce que quand
il parlait de concertation ils nous
disaient mais justement ce qu'on veut
faire et c'est vrai que ça c'est dans
les projets éducatifs territoriaux ce
qu'on veut faire c'est redonner aux
acteurs locaux de l'éducation c'est à
dire au maire aux enseignants et à tous
ceux y compris aux parents qui
s'occupent de l'éducation le pouvoir
justement de choisir un petit peu
comment ils vont s'organiser dans le
cadre de cette réforme
donc elle ça c'est très intéressant
alors après bien sûr qu'il ya certains
alors il pas partout hein mais il ya
certains endroits où il ya des problèmes
de gestion financière c'est ça ne passe
pas par exemple pour lyon pour paris on
a du mal justement à faire évoluer cette
loi est ce que 2013
est-ce qu'on s'arrête en 2013 ou est ce
qu'on essaie de le remettre à plus tard
à 2014 pour éviter que ce soit un échec
moi je pense que il y a des beaucoup de
mères qui veulent bien faire et qui se
disent pourquoi pas prendre un peu le
temps pour le faire correctement
moi j'entends ça simplement
je suis un peu inquiète parce que là je
moi je me dis qu'on est en février que
ceux qui vont le faire pour 2013 ont un
peu le temps donc je de février ils ont
plus de six mois pour préparer la chose
et ils vont avoir des aides pour ça ceux
qui veulent le faire en 2014 qui donc il
ne s'en occupe pas maintenant ce qu'ils
vont s'occuper d'assez d'une campagne
des municipales qui va prendre tout leur
temps donc ils n'auront pas le temps de
s'en occuper jusqu'aux élections
municipales
si c'est dans l'ancien maire après il
faut quand même qu'il installe son
équipe et c'est ça va repousser à caen
sa loi repoussé à mars avril mai et
finalement il aura encore moins de temps
que maintenant s'occuper de cette
réforme et encore plus si c'est un
changement de majorité lot s'est attelée
maintenant moi je me dis que quelque
part si on prend juste là en compte la
question du temps pour le faire
bah finalement ils ont peut-être un peu
plus de temps maintenant même si
j'entends encore une fois les
inquiétudes notamment financières que
peuvent avoir certains certains maires
et nous on va essayer de faire passer
l'idée qu' une péréquation pour aider
les communes les plus en difficulté mais
il ya aussi beaucoup de communes qui ne
sont pas en difficulté et qui est
franchement pourrait le faire si on ne
prend que le point de vue financier
alors passez au mercredi et on parle à
nouveau du cumul des mandats
le gouvernement a saisi le conseil
d'état c'est une première étape avant
l'arrivée du projet de loi fin mars en
conseil des ministres mais la loi sur le
non cumul des mandats ne devrait pas
être appliquée avant la fin du
quinquennat le projet divise à gauche ça
on le savait harlem désir désir et bien
il veut référendum et sans jeu de mots à
droite on dit chiche
s'il ya des blocages la fois sur le plan
politique et au plan constitutionnel
moi j'ai rappelé que les français
peuvent être saisis et qu'ils
apporteront leur soutien à cette
référendum
c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est une décision
qui ne peut relever que du président de
la république mais je crois que chacun
doit avoir présent à l'esprit que s'il y
avait un blocage sur le plan politique
ou s'il y avait une difficulté
constitutionnel cette possibilité du
référendum existe et je suis absolument
convaincu du soutien des français à une
loi qui instaurerait le non cumul des
mandats a parlé de désir nous dit
allant au référendum et bien moi je dis
chiche alors au référendum
ça nous dérange absolument pas
d'ailleurs nous avons vécu nous qui
sommes député-maire au sénateur-maire
déjà des référendum des référendums
locaux à l'occasion des élections
municipales et des élections
législatives n'ont pas peur des
électeurs ne vont pas peur du point de
vue des français n'avons pas peur du
débat
oui à des états généraux et pourquoi pas
oui au référendum alors barbara pompe il
et on a entendu harlem désir il ya une
certaine pression de la part du ps et
pourtant le gouvernement
il attend peut-être attendre 2017 pour
le faire je trouve ça dommage d'attendre
parce que d'abord d'abord ça répond
vraiment à une demande là pour le coup
de la population qui qui souhaitent
arrêter avec le cumul des mandats pour
plein de bonnes raisons j'sais pas si on
reviendra sur le fond après mais sur la
forme
j'entends il ya une inquiétude qui peut
être entendu qui est ce la fameuse
inquiétude la mini dissolution c'est à
dire que comme il ya beaucoup de
fidélité native un peu partout des
partiels cinquantaine j'attire partiel
lors de deux législatives partielles
parce que pour l'instant donc si un
député qui cumule donc arrête son mandat
de député pour rester uniquement maire
il n'est pas remplacé par son suppléant
il est il ya une nouvelle élection dont
une raison purement électoralistes alors
il peut y avoir cette inquiétude de
perdre une majorité et que c'est pas
seulement électoralistes c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin aussi d'un peu de
stabilité sur cinq ans si on veut mener
en place des politiques
donc moi je l'entends dire attendons
parce que on peut très bien maintenant
on peut très bien à sortir la réforme du
cumul d'une réforme alors il faudrait
peut-être qu'elles soient
constitutionnelles 6g si j'ai bien
compris les constitutionnalistes qui
permettrait justement d'être remplacé
par son suppléant ce qui règlerait le
problème quasiment partout et
je pense que des mesures comme ça il ya
toujours de bonnes raisons de les
repousser toujours mais on en parle
depuis 20 ans
voilà et maintenant les gens vraiment
envie que de passer à autre chose et moi
quand j'entends daniel fasquelle qui dit
que seuls les députés les députés maires
seraient les bons députés parce qu'ils
auraient un lien avec le avec le terrain
alors je m'inscris en faux totalement là
dessus moi je suis une députée et kinés
qui n'est pas d'autre mandat
et je peux vous dire que je ne pourrais
pas bien faire mon travail si je ne vais
pas un lien constant avec ce qui se
passe dans ma circonscription parce que
ce qui se passe dans ma circonscription
c'est un exemple de ce qui se passe
voilà sur le terrain et les difficultés
que rencontrent les gens je peux vous
dire je les vois tous les jours dans ma
permanence après des assemblées
d'experts comme on dit non ça c'est ce
que dit daniel fasquelle mais le système
biya des constitutionnalistes aussi qui
disent ça deviendrait le système
électoral de notre argent tel qu'il est
actuellement une élection se fait sur
une circonscription on pourrait revenir
d'ailleurs là-dessus mais là le fait
d'être réduits sur ma circonscription je
peux vous garantir que si les électeurs
ne voit pas pendant cinq ans eh ben ils
ne voudront plus pour nous la fois
d'après et quelque part c'est un moyen
encore une fois même si ce système
électoral ne me va pas très bien mais là
pour le coup il garantit une présence
sur le terrain alors autres sujets sont
plus sarkozy ce que nicolas sarkozy
lui-même et oui les nostalgiques de
l'ancien président se sont réunis à
paris marc rodier à la tribune chacun
est venu vanter le bilan de la politique
étrangère de nicolas sarkozy mais dans
les couloirs une question une seule
nicolas sarkozy sera-t-il le candidat de
la droite pour 2017 reportage sur place
signée fabrice qu'une et comment
afficher ses ambitions sont froissés
l'image de nicolas sarkozy c'est
l'exercice délicat auquel se sont livrés
certains cadres de l'ump aujourd'hui de
nathalie kosciusko morizet à bruno le
maire passage obligé sous la bannière de
l'association des amis de l'ancien
président et face aux caméras le plus
fidèle en amitié serait toujours jean
françois copé
mais d'autres cachent de plus en plus
mal leur désir d'émancipation à l'image
de nathalie kosciusko morizet dimanche
sarkozy revienne c'est ça que vous dites
mais surtout vivement que l'alternance
arrive incarné par nicolas sarkozy
arrive et ça sera encore là pour celui
qui sera le mieux placé pour l'incarner
qu'est ce que le sujet c'est
l'alternance ou pour vous dites vous
même il ya des débats de personnes
allaient l'on me dit quoi ça moi je vous
réponds et les vagues personne sans rien
si tout le monde est rassemblé la même
projet et le projet aujourd'hui pour moi
c'est la préparation l'alternance c'est
clair l'association des amis de nicolas
sarkozy revendique 30 mille membres
guillaume pelletier on est l'un des
fondateurs pour lui ce bal des
prétendants n'a pas lieu d'être
ce qui est incontestable c'est qu'on a
besoin du talent jean françois copé du
talent de françois fillon mais que le
leader naturel de la droite française
pour moi et pour nous ça reste nicolas
sarkozy était en forme de leadership ou
simplement de leadership
il est en en 1 puis ce qui s'appelle
nicolas sarkozy entretenir la flamme
c'était l'objectif de ce colloque est
tous les moyens sont bons du soutien
d'ingrid betancourt à la commande de
sondages flatteurs
le rendez-vous sera répétée une
démonstration de force histoire de
mettre les ambitions sous cloche au
moins jusqu'en 2017 alors à ce que pour
la droite le meilleur candidat reste
nicolas sarkozy moi je trouve ça un peu
triste en fait qu'encore je vois ça oui
non mais on
mais c'est assez c'est mais non c'est
même triste pour la démocratie parce que
quelque part ça arrive elle croise ça
révèle qu'on a une droite qui est
complètement paumé qui ne sait pas gérer
en fait nos positions qui a beaucoup de
mal à reconstruire un discours mêmes
reconstruire des propositions parce que
le rôle de l'opposition c'est de
proposer des alternatives proposées
d'autres choses dans plein de domaines
politique économique
là pour l'instant ce que je vois on a vu
tout à l'heure sur l'île sur la sphère
de des couacs soi-disant de croissance
on commente on commente la forme etc
mais on a beaucoup de mal à reconstruire
du fonds est sous le maillot du mal à
parler du fond et b et mel à la ccl que
c'est quand même fou parce que ils nous
disent tous non ce qu'on veut c'est
préparer l'alternance etc
mais on ne parle pas d'alternance on a
une espèce de nostalgie vis-à-vis du
leader disparu et est quelque part le
fait de se regrouper comme ça pour dire
on aime nicolas sarkozy ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on est cons et
qu'on ne sait pas parler de
reconstruction politique donc bah on
s'accroche à des voix là à des symboles
bon sur le fond ils ont parlé de
politique étrangère mais ça la politique
de l'environnement est ce que le bilan
de nicolas sarkozy est il si mauvais que
cela on parle souvent du grenelle de
l'environnement et surtout est-ce que
françois hollande ont fait plus alors
sur le grenelle de l'environnement sur
la méthode c'était quelque chose de très
intéressant et d'ailleurs nous on avait
salué à l'époque même si on était dans
l'opposition à ce moment là il a eu une
idée intéressante
il l'a même mené jusqu'au bout puisqu'il
ya eu des tables rondes des rencontres
tous les acteurs ont été associés y
comprises sociation environnementale
donc c'était c'était vraiment une bonne
idée
ce qui est dommage c'est que derrière il
faut du courage politique pour mettre en
place des politiques telles que celle ci
qui s'opposent à de nombreux lobbys et
on a vu
vu que au moment de mettre en
application cela hormis quelques
éléments sur le logement sur les
isolations au logement qui ont quand
même été mis en place
sinon pour le reste ça a été des reculs
donc françois hollande est plus écolo
condé je le sens je pense que les
socialistes d'une manière générale non
pas dans leur adn
l'écologie c'est quelque chose qui ne
fait pas partie de leur culture
politique et c'est pas évident de le
faire entrer même s'ils ont même si
c'est oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas
uniforme
on sent que quand même ses idées
commencent à rentrer chez certains
socialistes et on sent qu'il se rende
compte qu'il ya un enjeu est là pour le
coup c'est vraiment là qu'on doit être
utile et c'est pour pousser cet enjeu là
et pour convaincre et pour leur montrer
que l'écologie n'est pas l'ennemi de
l'économie bien au contraire
l'écologie c'est le développement
économique d'aujourd'hui et de demain et
ce jeudi a été marquée par un autre
retour celui ci un vrai retour celui de
ségolène royal
la désormais co président de la banque
publique d'investissement a fait son
retour sur le devant de la scène
politique c'était jeudi à dijon la bpi
ce premier engagement de campagne de
françois hollande a réuni son premier
conseil d'administration sur place et
les abarth lomé et jean baptiste daoulas
c'est elle qui la première en avait eu
l'idée une banque servant à financer les
petites et moyennes entreprises
logique selon ses partisans qu'elle soit
nommée vice présidente et porte parole
de la banque publique d'investissement
mais ses détracteurs crient au copinage
ségolène royal s'en défend je pense
qu'elles sont elles sont dégradant de
ses accusations elle sont méprisante et
je crois que ça suffit maintenant un
minimum de respect pour lui pour ceux
qui travaillent un minimum de respect
pour les entreprises et je voudrais dire
à ceux qui ont toujours le dénigrement à
la bouche qui ferait mieux de faire des
propositions au lieu de tomber dans dans
ces polémiques ridicules et nocive pour
l'économie sont pourtant tout avait mal
commencé
gare de lyon ce matin le train à
destination de dijon emmène tout le
conseil d'administration de la bpi
tout le monde est là sauf la nouvelle
vice présidente ségolène royal a loupé
son train faux départ pour la présidente
de la région poitou charentes sujet
railleries
sur la bpi j'ai envie de dire que c'est
l'histoire d'un trains qui arrivent à
l'heure
sans fureur sans fracas calmement
tranquillement sereinement mais
fortement mais déjà en privé
l'ancienne candidate à la présidentielle
à vous elle a d'autres projets et
pourquoi pas un poste au gouvernement
des ambitions vivement balayé par l'hôte
de la journée
françois patriat que ségolène royal qui
a j'imagine encore des ambitions ne se
limitent pas à celles de la
vice-présidence de la dpi aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est plutôt un lieu de
travail qu'un lieu de l'ascension
politique c'est pas vraiment un lieu où
on va demain gagné des parts de marché
électoral
ségolène royal objet de toutes les
attentions aujourd'hui on en oublierait
presque qu'il y à aussi un deuxième
vice-président à la bpi jean paul huchon
on va parler du fond bien évidemment
mais en commentaire évidemment aussi la
république des coquins c'est le retour
non c'est pareil moi ce que j'ai envie
c'est de voir ce que les gens font
ségolène royal qui a ses qualités ses
défauts on ne peut pas dire que ce sujet
là n'est pas un sujet qui n'a pas porté
ses c'est une de celles qui a envisagé
cette idée de bankuy d'investissement
c'est une de celles d'ailleurs chez
déchets des socialistes qui est plus
sensible au vert un investissement dans
justement la reconversion écologique de
l'économie
donc pour moi elle fait partie des gens
alors après il y en avait-il d'autres
j'en sais rien mais elle fait partie des
gens qui étaient tout à fait légitimes
pour pour rentrer à la vice-présidence
je vous dis que tu avais très proche de
françois hollande ségolène royal l'autre
connaît aussi l'histoire
ça fait un petit peu beaucoup dans pour
la seule bpi mois encore une fois
j'entends ça maintenant je ne vois pas
trop comment d'en sortir dans la mesure
où elle représente les associés
l'association des régions de france et
toutes quasiment toutes les régions sont
socialistes donc que l'association des
régions de france décident d'envoyer une
socialiste ça me paraît pas complètement
anormal et encore une fois je pense que
la meilleure réponse à ces accusations
la ce sera de voir le travail qu'ils
font
le fond justement cette banque financera
pour bien expliquer les pme prometteuses
et soutiendra les filières d'avenir au
total 40 2 milliards d'euros une grande
une grande ambition donc est ce que ça
peut virer à l'origine à gaz cette
histoire j'espère bien que non j'espère
bien que non parce que on ne sait jamais
on ne sait jamais mais là on est sur un
an
un des outils qui nous paraissent très
important justement pour relancer
l'économie en soutien aux pme qui sont
quand même l'architecturé économique de
notre pays
et en plus pour financer nous on avait
été très attentifs quand on avait parlé
de la création de la bpi justement pour
financer la transition énergétique et
d'une manière générale la conversion
écologique de l'économie
c'est un outil qu'on compte bien
utiliser et là pour le coup qui doit
faire partie justement des
investissements nécessaires pour
relancer la machine économique
moi vraiment au delà des polémiques sur
des personnes qui passionne tout le
monde je comprends bien et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est vraiment là c'est tout
il a pour relancer le marché de l'emploi
dans notre pays et pour relancer cette
fameuse compétitivité que tout le monde
que tout le monde ici d'ici un an quand
les pays on a fait rentrer un premier
bilan d'étape au bout d'un an et puis au
bout de au bout du quinquennat
mais voilà un outil mois dans lequel je
mets beaucoup d'espoir dernier sujet de
cette émission a parlé du salon de
l'agriculture qui ouvre ses portes ce
week-end il fête ses 50 ans alors
évidemment on va beaucoup parler de la
polémique autour de la viande de cheval
mais pas seulement car le salon de
l'agriculture c'est aussi une histoire
50 ans d'histoire de petite et grande
histoire avec paul bouffard
quelle réussite
tel est le jugement porté par le général
de gaulle sur le livre d'or du salon de
l'agriculture après sa visite détaillée
1964 première édition du salon
international de l'agriculture à paris
porte de versailles s'ouvre la plus
grande ferme d'europe dans un contexte
du tout agricoles les paysans sont
nombreux près de 4 millions 4 fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui
bauvin poule chiens mais aussi chevaux
l'affluence flirte souvent avec les
records entre 1970 et 1980 on dépasse
même le million de visiteurs
pour le vétérinaire larcher le salon est
une piqûre de rappel pour entretenir
l'importance de l'agriculture française
s'était toujours quand même une super
fête où j'accompagnais mon père qui
était un élu d'une commune rurale et où
le matin encore à ce moment là ont
préparé les plus belle jument
percheronne en leur faisant détresse et
en mettant du ruban tricolore
miroir des agriculteurs mais aussi lieu
de débat depuis 50 ans le salon vite au
rythme des difficultés de la profession
l'histoire des farines animales afin
bref la pollution des sols quand on a eu
l'épisode sanitaire de la vache folle on
a vu sur le salon il y avait des débats
des interrogations en 1973 un homme
tombe amoureux du salon c'est jacques
chirac il fait de la visite politique
une institution qui n'a jamais vu son
goût pour la cochonnaille et les vins
français suit la chance de vivre une
visite présidentielle donc de jacques
chirac
j'ai passé choix 10 12 heures je ne sais
pas aux côtés du président chirac qui
est un animal politique sans le savez de
très haut niveau mais quelqu'un qui
aimait les gens qui sentent l
agriculture un salon qui aura vu le
monde agricole changer profondément dans
ses allées les paysans sont devenus
agriculteurs et les fermes des
exploitations barbara opinion le voile
au sein de l'agriculture c'est
évidemment un lieu de débat rva
évidemment parler sûrement de ce
scandale de la viande de cheval le
ministre stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture dit que nous avons affaire
à une fraude généralisée c'est quoi
c'est la mafia de la malbouffe une mafia
européenne alors il faudra voir comment
s'est organisé tout ça mais quelque part
weis douter que ce genre de choses
finirait par arriver on a déjà eu des
alertes grave avec le système la vache
folle la crise de la vache folle et on
est sur un système qui a qui a éloigné
au fur et à mesure en fait le
l'agriculture les produits des gens donc
on est maintenant sur des systèmes où on
a des animaux qui sont abattues dans un
pays qui sont découpées dans un autre
qui sont encore enfin conditionné encore
dans un autre et on voit bien que c'est
complètement aberrant et on devait en
plus dedans il ya évidemment le passage
par les paradis fiscaux parce que comme
ça ça permet de spéculer sur des
produits de première nécessité ce qui
est quand même même moralement
complètement répréhensible
je crois que le système en lui même
porter sa du système où l'agriculture
aussi évidemment vous mini de
l'agriculture peut-être un jour pour
l'interrogation
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait plus vous
les verts jeu bien sûr nous ce qu'on
voudrait c'est déjà rapproché des gens
de la terre quelque part et donc que
l'agriculture redevienne une agriculture
qui prennent en compte les saisons qui
prenne en compte la proximité
on voit d'ailleurs que healy a notamment
non non parce que justement alors ça peu
moins se faire en picardie où je suis où
on a un vrai problème des éleveurs
laitiers qui sont dans des situations
terribles mais on voit que dans d'autres
régions notamment plus montagneuses des
éleveurs laitiers justement pour se
donner de l'avenir ils se sont regroupés
pour refaire du local pour refaire des
circuits courts pour refaire et puis on
pour refaire aussi de la qualité parce
que ce qu'on voit au salon de
l'agriculture c'est quand même l'amour
des produits l'amour de la qualité
l'amour de la richesse des produits de
france et c'est ça qu'on doit promouvoir
et je peux vous dire que là dessus on
peut être très compétitive et notre
polémique vous avez posé une question au
gouvernement ici même à l'assemblée
cette semaine c'est sur la farine de
viande animale réintroduite par à
bruxelles
le ministre garraud vous a répondu dans
l'hémicycle est optimiste pour la suite
vous avez encore des craintes suite à la
réponse du ministre la réponse du
ministre était une réponse assez flou
quand même hein donc nous on va reposer
la question pour avoir des éléments plus
précis il nous a dit qu'il était contre
cette réintroduction
et c'est pareil quoi on marche sur la
tête
on marche sur la tête on va redonner des
farines animales dont on sait ce que ça
a créé alors maintenant on nous dit vous
inquiétez pas tout est sous contrôle
quand on voit la manière dont est
contrôlé la viande qui étaient destinés
à la nourriture des humains la viande
qu'on a vu dans le dans les lasagnes
j'ai quand même des doutes sur la
qualité des contrôles sur les farines
qu'on va donner à des poissons
voyez d'abord de l'agriculture à givet
très régulièrement parce que j'adore ça
c'est vraiment une ambiance très
spéciale cette année avec la loi sur
l'école et les suspensions
je ne suis pas sûr de ce couloir je
serai prêt vient l'accueillir en général
oui oh ça dépend ça aussi ça dépend il y
avait eu des sondages dominique voynet
quand elle était ministre mais je pense
que les agriculteurs les agriculteurs
comme moi j'ai rencontré dans ma
circonscription et que je vais continuer
à rencontrer se rend bien compte que les
écologistes sont pas les hauts de par le
manque d'eau merci papa pompier d'avoir
été notre invité cette semaine et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même
humeur bonne semaine à tous